Kendra's with us in Orlando Florida hi
Kendra how are you
hi I'm doing good thank you so my
husband and I have a leased car and
we've had it for about two years now and
we have two years left on the contract
we owe about seven thousand and the
residual value is about eighteen
thousand and we are over about eight
thousand miles which will be allotted
knowledge so we're wondering if we
should trade that car in to buy a new
car and finance that or if we should
keep this car until the end of the lease
I feel like we're kind of just putting
money into something that we're never
gonna have yeah because you're renting
your car um the here's what you need to
find out and this number you don't have
yet is what your early buyout figure is
the seven thousand you gave me is what
is what your remaining payments are
right on the two years right okay and
you're 18 and you said the residual was
what about eighteen thousand okay so 25
is the total of those so I'm gonna guess
your early buyout would probably be in
the 22 or 23 range okay something like
that because you're early bio it's like
paying your car payment or paying your
yeah your card debt off early you don't
you're not charged the interest through
the end of the lease they give you a
discount for paying it off early okay
okay and so that's what you're looking
for is the early buyout amount now let's
pretend for a second that's 22 and let's
pretend for a second that this car is
worth today have you looked up what it's
worth today yet I looked up what the
trade-in value was okay what was that it
was what 20,000 okay then the private
sale value is gonna be about 22 or so
maybe 23 meaning if you sold it to an
individual you would get more than
wholesaling it to a dealer do you see
what I'm saying right trade-in is
wholesale that's what a dealer will buy
it
and then they're going to resell and
make money on that and that doesn't make
them evil but that's the business
they're in and you can sell it and make
more money by selling it yourself as the
point you can if you can pay it off for
twenty two and you can sell it for
twenty two let's do that you have any
money anywhere um see we have maybe step
one and three done but we're still
working on - so you don't know how to
put the baby steps in order honey no
it's hard to see a huge chunk of money
going and we only have how much is in
your in your savings account
we have total about twenty thousand okay
write a check today and pay off your
three thousand dollars in death that's
just stupid
okay now then go buy you a car and pay
cash for it and then rebuild your
emergency fund you know we want to
upgrade in cars because we have a family
in work you don't have the money way
right you're gonna have to make a car
that's $15,000 work oh well okay you
know or twelve thousand dollars for a
period of time what's your household
income it's about thirty right now my
husband's in school so that'll change
over the next two years but about thirty
right now what what is he taking in
school he's doing information technology
okay all right you need to definitely
get out of this car lease by selling the
car for twenty to twenty-two is gonna be
your approximate payoff and you need to
pay cash for a car that you can afford
you're driving a freakin twenty six
thousand dollar car with a thirty
thousand dollar income there's nowhere
on this planet that that makes sense
that's nuts
so that's what you should do you should
buy a car you can afford so you need to
be $10,000 $12,000 car pay cash for it
write a check today pay off the three
thousand dollars in debt that you have
and sell your lease car for enough to
pay off the lease if you're a little bit
of short out of that take a little bit
of money out of your savings and get rid
of that car today and be done with that
leased car is you have a leased car in
your driveway that's just absolutely
insane yeah okay that's what I would do
so at the end of the day you're going to
end up with about four or five thousand
dollars in your account and no car
payments and a ten or twelve thousand
dollar car sitting in your driveway and
making thirty thousand dollars now that
starts to look like sanity again then we
rebuild the emergency fund because now
you're home to baby step three and now
you're actually doing the baby steps in
order wallah you move down in car oh
well you make thirty thousand dollars a
year
ten thousand twelve thousand our car's
fine when he moves comes out of school
he starts making some really good money
you move up in car with cash but you
don't move up in car from a car you
can't afford already in this scenario
that's insane I mean you go from
insanity to double insanity no not a
chance
don't know if you're gonna do any of
that but that's what you should do
thanks for calling in hey guys thanks
for watching if you enjoyed this video
click the subscribe button to get the
latest content and check out these other
great clips from the show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
Oh